[Applause]
[Music]
oh my
God my
right you got some fans there's some
fans wasn't that amazing didn't that
sound incredible I was there so much
talent under this roof like there's so
much talent 30 Rock I thought it was the
coolest idea that Jason had but it's the
holidays y'all so do you'all have any
plans what are you doing are you taking
time off you've been working yeah we've
been working we've been working so uh
looking forward to some time with the
just like
this yeah yeah that's what I'm asleep
and eating yeah yeah did you enjoy New
Orleans this is where you shot right
yeah just outside of
it I had an end of tour party there and
I slightly remember it yeah it was it's
a really fun city can be incredible Good
Food City great food I know I love it
there that can't live there for that
reason you get recognized at restaurants
all the time now because of the Bear
right I do yeah yeah do you love that do
you get like
impeccable do you get like impeccable
service I feel like they're going to try
and impress you yeah I get I get taken
care of it's really really nice yeah
yeah yeah I never leave a restaurant
hungry would go to to dinner and like
they would just bring out so much free
food it was a very nice perk of going to
dinner with Jer it was nice um so you're
you're um Harris you're the only
non-american so was it hard for the
Texas accent it was it was I mean I felt
like it was in between like I think I
was saying the other day like on set I
think people are a little confused by
how to like talk to you like some of the
grips and the crew are like not quite
sure where you're from or like are you
putting on are you joking with the
British accent or is it like a oh no
it's a good bit it's a good bit yeah but
you did such an amazing job with him
thank kind of hard to do because there's
so many different dialects in each state
as well like depending on if you're from
North Texas or you know what I'm saying
there's so many different I think you
did great I'm from North Texas yeah I
think you did great you exactly I would
tell I wouldn't have brought it up if I
thought you sucked at you just been like
like I would have just left it alone
yeah I will say there's so much footage
on the the brothers like the real life
brothers that we play there is so much
like it's a huge thing in Texas yeah
really yeah even if you weren't into
wrestling you knew who they were yeah
yeah such a big um family in Texas did
you did you kind of have to research the
family to really get into the characters
yeah yeah yeah we did a lot of research
um and it was really fun to learn about
the Von Erics they're kind of like the
kennedies of wrestling that's an analogy
I've heard before so luckily we had so
much help Chavo guer our um sort of
mentor and and like Sensei was just
awesome to learn from and he he knew the
guys too a little bit he comes from like
a a wrestling Dynasty himself and the
whole movie really is a love letter to
Texas man and uh to play the Von Erics
out there was was very special we had a
real crowd around oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm wearing Shades I don't mean to be uh
like I just thought you st
man no I I hurt my I'm just kidding they
told me that no one time no not one time
two times I've had to wear an eye patch
on this show hey yeah it's super fun I
look like a pirate but and when you do
it two days that's actually four shows
so because you do two a day so yeah I've
look like a pirate on here so you look
cool you chose wisely I should have gone
with Shades next time I slit my eye once
like in makeup and and it yeah and it it
sucks yeah hair hair and makeup's hard
man it's brutal it's hard it can be
brutal yeah this is why you won't
recognize me in Target yeah I don't
they're like everybody walks by and
they're like is that no yeah I just try
and not talk my accent will give it away
that was a look at their new movie The
Iron CLS in theaters
tomorrow okay I H I have questions but
look I just saw that like how hard was
it to look like that like were you
miserable a little bit was yeah you're
so lean yes what did you have like no
body fat I mean at that point it was
pretty low was a statue we had to like
wrestle and touch it was like an ice
sculpture it was insane oh my God but it
was fun man I got to kind of disappear
for seven or eight months and just
really focus on that with a clear goal
um and yeah that kind of getting into
that mode I think really helped with the
character in so many ways so absolutely
it was it was challenging but it it was
fun to uh to go into that zone for look
at you're flying you're like a superhero
in the air like what
oh my God I had to I had to ask y did
y'all all y'all all have to beef up
you're all wrestling at some point so
you're all doing stuff so like did y'all
all have to kind of do that yeah yeah we
all had to eat much more food than I
think we were used to and uh i' have
been ready for that roll yeah and um and
lift and lift a lot of heavy things and
yeah we all tried to get bigger I don't
know you're eating pretty boring stuff
though it's chicken rice lot of chicken
and rice and veggies I was e what I want
I have a strict of a thing because David
wasn't as ripped I told myself yeah we
made yeah we made made a rule that
didn't have to be as ripped I love that
what is the ironclaw tell everybody
because it's like the family move right
is that what it is yeah yeah it's
created by Fritz uh our Our Father who
was a wrestler yeah um and yeah um
basically it's it's uh it's like a
finishing move uh for yeah our father
Fritz is it like you grab yeah it's like
his hand kind of he loses control of it
and kind of just like grabs your face
and um the real Fritz was pretty crazy
about it man he would uh he would hurt
these the real frit is kind of intense
yeah that's an intense family this story
is there's a lot to it yeah it's brutal
yeah yeah a lot of tragedy yeah felt for
some reason all Texas film's done
there's a lot of Despair and there is
like a lot of like even Friday Night
Lights like all those things you watch
it's like kind of like very destructive
we got to work on that Texas did y'all
watch wrestling growing up did any of
yall watch it I did do you watch it
Stanley you're speaking too much to oh
sorry you're too loud definitely I uh I
had a cousin who was very into it and uh
I definitely had a John Cena action
figure growing up and I was terrified of
uh The Undertaker and and and Kane um
but uh yeah I didn't know about that Von
Erics um it was really interesting yeah
there was a lot of footage uh on YouTube
We I I think I can speak for all of us
when I say we scoured and and watched so
many of their matches and uh their
interviews it was it was really
interesting did y'all go to a match
together did y'all go to something
together we did we did we did in New
Orleans there was a local match on one
of our trainers Luke Hawks was was
fighting in a match so we went to that
it was fun yeah it's so crazy it's like
a real event yeah oh I my no I don't
know if anyone knows this my very first
singing job was singing the national
anth I got asked to sing at a wrestling
thing I knew nothing about wrestling no
way and I showed up in a dress similar
to
this cuz I didn't know and and it was
like a local thing and I was like and I
felt way overdressed and I had no idea
what was happening it was a craziest
thing I've ever done but I loved it it
was like but it is a if you never
experienced it you walk and you're like
what my brother came who had never seen
or really heard of like wrestling in
this format remember my brother he was
like what is happening like it's int was
blown away great and people get beat
up definitely uh we took we took we had
a lot of bumps and bruises over the
course of filming this but um you you
kind of got lucky you got to wear a nice
dress in the ring that's weet yeah you
got to wear underwear yeah and and
something there was something uh you
know unique about that moment I think
that all of us stepped into the ring for
the first time in our underwear very
vulnerable yeah very vulnerable and like
we had sort of all just been shaved
down oh cuz they have to shave your
whole body did y'all I heard that y'all
did that did y'all do that together you
all got the same time we very nice
romance very nice romance I'll tell you
what it instantly made us Brothers No
going You're Just In It Together Shand
some embarrassment so you had to learn I
knew we all knew you could dance this
was not Shock
but there was line dancing which is very
different kind of dancing but yeah but
did you were you prepared for line
dancing the embarrassing thing is we did
have prep time with a teacher to show us
how to do that and it was still quite
difficult once we actually got there
yeah actually what was funny is I sh for
the scene and everybody was uh really
good at this dance and I I I was not
aware that they had rehearsals cuz I was
shooting some wrestling at the time but
uh so I thought I was really falling
behind I like I had seen the St and they
were all seem like professionals um so
trying to keep up was was pretty funny
that's not true dud showed up we were
all
annoyed you guys didn't have the
training and you and ly crushed it you
just watched us once and was like all
right yeah yeah well you both you and
Lily I had Lil on as well you both have
like musical background as well so I
think that they probably knew that too
they were like they'll be fine they got
it yeah but I just love watching Men
dance that aren't used to it sure it's
nothing more fun it is a nice it is a
nice
so
Stanley you did something very fun cuz
like everyone on my crew is a High
School Musical fan and
so it's like it's like American Idol
you're never going to get away you know
what I'm saying it's kind of cool though
that people know you and and love you
from that but I heard that you did a
tribute to Zach impromptu on set yeah I
mean I think uh anyone from my
generation I I I think it would be a
disservice to anyone from my generation
if I if I didn't do something and and uh
and uh yeah I mean we had like a Live
party scene we did we did and uh I I was
playing music and I the night before I
was fretting about the scene and the
night before I I learned the chords to
to to Breaking Free and and I uh gave a
little rendition uh in in front of in
front of Zach and it was and it was
right before my coverage it was welled
oh it's right before you have to like be
serious or something yeah yeah it was
pretty funny he did it kind of sneaky as
well he was like sorry
like did you enjoy the Tre do you enjoy
when people still come up to I still
look it's been over 20 years but I still
love when people like I voted for you
because I'm like thank you um but like
do you well thank you it worked um but
do you still love it like cuz it's one
of those things that I think when people
first get to know you there's something
special about it oh definitely I mean I
cuz you were a baby yeah u i mean it
means the world it's so fun I the other
day in Hollywood uh got a star on The
Walker oh
congratulations that's awesome man um
but there were there were so many wild
cat jerseys out and the fans are are
still out there in Forest it's fun
though cuz you know they they used to be
uh you know really young and now now
it's there's like there's like
40-year-old there yeah so it's awesome
man like I love it I love I love it it
PR promotes like a pretty cool Nostalgia
for people like you know from from back
in the day that's pretty cool yeah yeah
um well um there's a there is a curse
but they it's kind of there's a family
curse in the movie I mean it feels like
the family's cursed everything that
could possibly happen I feel like
happens to this family so are y'all
superstitious at all in real life do you
knock on wood do you do that thing yeah
knock on wood I won't go under ladder I
suppose I know what that one's about
umbrellas
inside um I try to avoid don't say good
luck before a uh performance on stage
say break a leg um do you do you believe
any supersti are you superstitious yeah
I mean uh I I wouldn't say I'm
superstitious but I I do do things
sometimes like yeah like like knocking
on wooden and spilling salt and I I I
have to like throw salt over my shoulder
I I don't really know why or like uh
when I'm walking a sidewalk I'll have to
like not step on a crack you know just
little things like that and I I don't
know the reason why I do that but we all
do it right I think from childhood
you're just yes we do it I I do um 11-11
make a wish still oh yeah and my
daughter is I think I've created a
monster because if she misses 11-11 she
loses it as if there are no wishes left
in the land well that one's real real I
love you so much okay how did your
families react to this
story they cried my brother cried a l it
was upsetting yeah if they didn't cry
that'd be
weird my my brothers came out of the
theater and they were just I had to
console them you know they were they
were perod my my real little brother's
definitely you know helped me play this
character and uh I get to be a big
brother in real life and it's awesome
but didn't realize how much it would
come into play in doing something like
this it really helped you know I got to
be the big brother for these guys and I
knew what I was doing so it good oh
that's cool well we have to take another
break on that sweet a moment um
Everybody give it up for the cast of The
ironclaw you can see them in
[Music]
the
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home